what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story not only was luffy's new
bounty revealed along with some other
bounties we also find out who the new
yonko are all four of them we find out
more about green bull and it's just all
shocking you guys will not believe this
one oda definitely went out with a bang
before his long break so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do enjoy
getting these early spoiler videos
before the full translated pages come
out and want to keep them coming chill
parking with it and smash that like
button with no mercy until it goes up in
fireworks like you're in the flower
capital having a big party always be a
smashing pirate king rather than a
passing orochi make this the video you
joined the knock come up by subscribing
and hitting that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
now is not the time to be missing one
piece so make sure you're subscribed and
now without further ado let's jump into
its spoilers and all so let's go back
and remember where we were at the end of
the last chapter for a second we had
that amazing oda tease where apu
straight up flashed newspapers in front
of law and kid saying that news is out
about what happened on wano and thus all
the bounties have been published along
with the names of the four new emperors
of the sea aka the new yonko it's so
shocking what it turns out to be but
we'll get there don't worry we'll get
there i'm just still so shocked we also
had green bull at the ending of the last
chapter approaching wano and we saw that
he had some kind of plant-based powers
since he was using a flower on his back
as a helicopter to fly so there was the
expectation that we'll learn more about
him and we do learn more about him in
this one so this chapter chapter 1053 is
called the new emperors a very
straightforward but at the same time
very hype chapter title we're told that
there's a color spread that's dedicated
to the one piece odyssey video game the
reason that i do get pretty hyped about
the games even though i haven't been a
big gamer recently is that oda usually
designs new characters with new devil
fruit powers for these games which even
if they are not technically canon are
always interesting to hear about
especially when oda drew the design and
came up with the bonus character himself
so in terms of this game that's what
i'll be on the lookout for more than
anything else let me know if you're
hyped about this game in the comments
and if there are any other one-piece
games out there that you'd recommend for
a one-piece stand to play back to the
spoilers and right away oda goes big
delivering on one of the big things that
was teased last chapter but it surprised
me not gonna lie we're told the new
bounties of luffy law and kid are out
and they are 3 billion berries each how
does that happen the image of luffy's
wanted poster is also shown and it's
gear 5 luffy although don't get me wrong
i'm hyped that they have his sun god
form on the poster it just doesn't make
sense to me how does luffy have the same
bounty as law and kid we saw much the
world government feared luffy's
awakening and then he went on to beat
the strongest creature by himself while
law and kit had to tag team big mom and
yet they each get 3 billion it's even
more confusing when we find out who the
new emperors actually are but again more
on that later because it's not revealed
yet for now back to the actual bounties
themselves and i get why the total was 9
billion since it's more than if you add
kaido's bounty of
4.6111 billion two big mobs bounty of
4.388 billion only slightly more but
still it's cool how they add up to 9
billion after they overcome the other
two yonko whose bounties add up to
8.991 billion would have definitely
planned this and i like it a lot and i
don't have a problem with the overall
numbers when you add them together what
i don't get is why luffy didn't get at
least 5 billion while the others each
got like 2 billion or something like
that luffy's should be higher than
kaido's in my view after all he beat him
but hopefully it'll make more sense when
the full translated pages come out some
of this stuff really got me to question
more than ever whether these spoilers
are legit but oro japan has always been
right about the spoilers every time i've
seen them up till now so it's unlikely
that the info is incorrect it's just
going to be about whether oda is good at
selling it why do you guys think luffy's
bounty is the same as laws and kids do
you think they are trying to purposely
downplay him so as not to attract more
attention to the new era sun god if so
it seems odd that they would use his
gear 5 picture another thought that came
to my mind is that the news might be
fake but that hasn't happened yet so far
in the story so your guess is as good as
mine at this point still i am confused
not sure how old is going to explain all
this we then find out that hitetsu is
revealed to be kozuki sukiyaki aka
former shogun of wano and father of odin
he was thought to be dead so it's quite
the twist and again goes to show that
dudes in masks usually aren't red
herrings but tend to be hiding something
we'll get more into this with the full
translated pages review which you should
subscribe for so you don't miss it when
it comes out but something that
immediately comes to mind is that now
the internally young momo could have
help from his grandfather who was also
shogun so that would make his job a lot
easier and it's nice that he'll get to
rely on his grandpa even if he
tragically can't rely on his dad anymore
robin who people have been wondering
about recently in the comments section
asking where she is in the last few
chapters well she is here she does
appear and she talks to sukiyaki and
says that pluton is in the land of wano
a huge ancient weapon update
unbelievable how much we're getting in
one chapter pluton aka the world's worst
battleship capable of destroying whole
islands in a single shot was set to
sleep somewhere in alabasta and
crocodile was talking about it way way
back in the day now we may actually get
to see it and i wonder how it'll come
into play would the straw hats actually
switch ships it's doubtful but something
has to happen with it let me know your
thoughts what is the fate of pluton
might the so-called world's worst
battleship go to the world's worst
criminal i don't know but the names
would go well together at the very least
we now jump to greenville whose name is
revealed to be aramaki so it does seem
like he is from moana since that's
definitely a water name he can create
plants no surprise there and this is new
he can absorb people's nutrients from
them we see him using this against king
and queen apparently another insane
encounter that oda just decided to throw
into this jam-packed chapter can't wait
to see this and in what condition king
and queen were in when green bull
presumably bested them like this there's
a big party in the flower capital their
fireworks and if you want to participate
just hit that like button and you too
will see the wano fireworks the least
party guy aka kid arrives at the party
and shows luffy the newspaper and again
something crazy happens truly crazy that
almost feels like an april fool's joke
it's revealed that the four new emperors
are shakes
blackbeard
luffy wait for it
and buggy yes at this point if buggy d
clown is not a d-clan member i'd
honestly be surprised i'm not gonna lie
i do love buggy and this is kind of
amazing to see him with this title it's
clearly not out of nowhere in the sense
that oda did prepare us for this by
making him a warlord first back in the
day could the world government be trying
to use him as a puppet i'd like to think
not but you never know i definitely
can't wait to hear the reason for why
buggy became ianko but again the weird
thing is if luffy is a yonko now clearly
above kid and law which we all expected
why would they have the same bounties as
him this chapter is definitely a real
head scratcher and i can't wait to find
out more about this insanity right here
it's so funny just monday we discuss the
first eight episodes of one piece in a
podcast i do link in the description and
how much we love the buggy and now as if
the answer that love oda gives us
another crowning achievement of buggies
he did say he'd become pirate king way
back in those early episodes and he's
definitely on his way at this point i
love it too because he and shanks were
pirate apprentices together and now they
are yonko together it's wild and yet i
can never be upset when buggy d clown
does epic things like this but that is
it for these insane spoilers is your
mind blown i feel like it has to be let
me know your thoughts mine is definitely
blown if you did enjoy and want to keep
the spoiler videos coming channel the
buggy within that's like beyond piraking
at this point like channel the buggy
within and smash that like button with
no mercy until it goes up in fireworks
and your room becomes the flower capital
always be a smashing pirate king or a
smashing buggy but never ever be a
passing orochi like i'd rather you smash
the dislike than pass like orochi
anyways make this the video you joined
the nakama by subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and as i
said now is not the time to be missing
one piece i'm telling you while you wait
for the full translated pages review to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos in all the yonko warlords
supernova mythical zones and much more i
can't even say them all there's so much
link to that is in the description and
i'll put the playlist on screen here as
well and until next time see ya space
cowboys